hello my name is Alison wrench today
we're gonna be talking that Amy Windsor
and the end of DOMA the Defense of
Marriage Act yes come on I could puke
tonight yeah let's just get it out of us
so the year is 1950 the place is the
United States of a at this point in
history it's not even legal to dance
closely to a person of the same sex so
EB Windsor was a young lesbian she's
like oh I gotta keep my personal life
private because this is the past in the
past just close minded so then Edie is
in Greenwich Village and she notices a
beautiful leggy brunette she is hey are
you can I dance with you
the woman goes hello my name is Thea
Spyer and yes that's a great name you
got Edie Windsor and Thea Spyer to like
cool lesbian names yeah you know and
then Edie goes is your dance card full
which is an old-timey way of being like
you single and then she goes it is now
meaning I'm ready they have poles in
them yes big girls so then they date and
they fall in love but then on June 28th
1969 she encounters the Stonewall Riots
where gay people were being
out-and-proud about who they were amid
this police raid at the Stonewall Inn so
she goes home and she was like Thea
there's the big riot at Stonewall about
gay rights maybe this is the moment that
we should come out and and and tell the
world who we really are so she's like I
don't know that's really risky maybe not
so Edie and Thea are like you know well
we're not revolutionaries we're just two
ladies are in love and like to dance and
we're gonna be private about it and they
do that for the next thirty
years that's a long time and the thing
that they really bonded over was dancing
in any situation
your body's cronies connect through
dance and it's about 2007 out
Anthea was in a wheelchair with MS Thea
was like I want to get married by this
time Canada had made gay marriage legal
so Thea and Edie go to Toronto and then
get married in four to six buddies they
exchanged rings and Edie and Thea are
like whoa this feels different to truly
be married like there's a tangible
difference this is not that's
very sweet to be like the Lord yeah
those were laws so in 2009 Thea dies and
Edie is there in the hospital and she's
like you know what I had a good life we
had a beautiful love what more could I
ask for and then knock knock good US
government says hey so your friend iya
left you a bunch of property money
assets and we don't recognize that cuz
you're two ladies it's not like you were
married so we're gonna tax you on the
order of half a million dollars and ego
is bitch you know we were married and
this is discrimination I'm gonna call a
bunch of lawyers I'm gonna call a bunch
of gay rights activist um so then she
says excuse me I was in a relationship
with this woman for forever
we got married in Toronto this is legit
they're not recognizing their marriage
so they're trying to tax the out of
me and that lawyers and activists are
like yeah that's DOMA you know since
1996 this law was enacted that says on a
federal level a marriage is between a
man and a woman and it's just
undefeatable undefeatable in you can't
do it but then Edie calls
Roberta Robbie
is her name Roberta Robbie Caplan her
fun name is Robbie her name is Roberta
Kaplan and this woman goes you know what
I'll take you on you are what marriage
is about you two were married for
decades through sickness and in health
your sweet old woman you're the perfect
example of what gay marriage can be so
Roberta and Edie mm-hmm sue the federal
government and it goes all the way to
the Supreme Court and Edie goes before
them and says if my love isn't real no
love is real you were together
for so long our love deserves to be
recognized
Wow okay so on June 26 2013
Edie and her supporters gather around a
computer pops up on the screen DOMA is
unconstitutional five to four everyone's
our friend cheer too hard to be perfect
so she goes back to Stonewall in
Greenwich Village
crowds were gather and they went Edie
Edie Edie and he thought to herself Wow
years ago when I walked past here during
the Stonewall Riots me and Thea thought
for now revolutionaries but here we are
years later and we are the
revolutionaries we're the face of what
gay marriage can be and Edie dances one
last dance in the name of the love of
her life via TPM and Edie and Evie
that's amazing
thanks to this one brave woman and her
belief in the Equality of her love gay
marriage became legal do you think in in
in memory of them that you and I should
dance we should dance so close well can
I give you what do
you